yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
Kelly I'm kallu demora very frequent
opponent and yeah I've activated this
statistic I have such a terrible score
against me usually from very good
position so it's a bit of a frustrating
statistics yeah even this as possible
yeah maybe it is Joanne Inc was a tough
nut to crack somehow I wonder if a five
maybe I should go 85 and intending a
queen bee six he will play Knights bd7
probably but then I wanted to prevent on
prevent a five-night a six this type of
setup hmm
is if I go see 5 and night a for this
IDM
hmm ok do that let's do that i'm not
sure about night h5 maybe he can
goodnight age 5 p.m. k didn't do it so
I'm able to preserve the bishop for the
moment k
my idea is that he's got problems with
the rook he probably needs to do
something to do free this book let's
let's do that night a4 b6 this straight
IDM you can take twice on b6 are
unbelievable the queen is saying I
immediately saw it I but II didn't okay
yeah then this masa are quite quite
successful operation okay should I take
b5
maybe you should maybe I should it can
take p6 again what the heck it take p6
now and now he's going to see it
probably I just I just need to move the
Queen to be 30 or somewhere yeah you
will see that Creek yeah yeah and after
Queen takes b6 I'm I'm I'm just I'm just
terribly worse am I yeah now I am worse
no doubt it's really it's really
frustrating I think it was an excellent
position just I just need to move the
Queen I can take on b5 next move now
this is some just very questionable okay
but still on let's let's try maybe maybe
i can i can check a play that and still
try it even without the sea por no it's
it's it's interesting
the point is also would have been
without blundering this that this after
a BF the gift half the book is have an
idea and after takes i have play on the
C file very good play on the CFL
so just Roxy one no problem and the
question is now 95 d7 now or is there a
better idea look see 70 s problem shall
be less I'm promising unless even have
an F 697 nice you got me five ok maybe
on f6 then I need to go 93 intending 95
this is still not wow he just announced
this with temple amazing
check it maybe you can
should I am is probably okay threatening
c6 now so Bishop c7 you will probably
suck the exchange I can prepare that the
bishop move now this is better anyway
playing with you fallen to try to try to
use the default
this and they are they are tactics here
very interesting tactics okay I cannot
calculate this I need to just just just
go for it look this 6 meter the point
yeah I missed a big chance again very
sure there was there was something
against the king
is going to play a rookie for something
kinky for Beckett rookie form time
morning yeah I know
bruxism made him it's the only very very
small idea white forfeits on time yeah
somehow I always play crap against this
guy I mean it's doing very very nice
things to let me win the game but I
simply simply don't manage this was the
first one I mean just this one and right
is an excellent champion i simply i have
this candidate porn on on b6 and this is
very very difficult for black to defend
various ideas let's say i don't know
what you should play the comp wants to
play f6 and g5 to even have some kind of
to some to have some kind of play let's
do that I just thought I have i canna
can I can play an alternate move orders
and overlook Queen B 6 for the second
time I just have this idea also to take
after pawn takes this c72 bread to c6 to
break through and after eight takes
there's always route 87 so I will get
something on the 7th and his bishops are
completely useless here I just forgot
about Queen B 6 again and played this
one can and then I got back in the game
and this again I think there should be
okay for light the round here isn't that
something when the computer doesn't
doesn't show anything from white I think
I'm okay again really I was just
thinking about playing for and for
foreign advantage here not like playing
for a draw maybe there is nothing the
King position really looks a bit bit
weird that's not only the simple idea
Rupert e6 mate is also
if he moves the King away from from from
the c6 squared LC six and I'm breaking
through but then it seems that there is
no no trick I mean this this wasn't
wasn't working but yeah yeah that's
simply not naughty this was stupid
because I will create but he's got he's
got it under control yeah then the the
real point of course was that I just
need to need to play here and black his
outplayed no question I could I could
maybe also go to some other square this
is this is a really debatable Queen a4
could be also an idea having this idea
but maybe providers queen bee three
years okay i just i overlooked this
twice yeah he could have taken here
already which she didn't see and i gave
him a second chance and it was
completely idiotic alright thanks for
watching